without missing a beat in the aftermath
of the buffalo mass shooting where a
racist 18 year old using
quite literally fox news talking points
in a manifesto allegedly left behind
went and sought out black people
um killed ten injured three eleven of
the victims black to white
fox news brought on a guest to speculate
about you know the violence has
correlated with the video games getting
really realistic and really violent
they're doing it
they're doing it with a straight face
look at this
i think of you know what must go through
the minds of these people like like the
guy yesterday who's accused of shooting
up that supermarket he's 18 years old
his whole life was in front of him and
now his life essentially is over because
of what he decided to do
do they not think about this before they
open fire are they so wrapped up in
themselves as you say so psychopathic
that nothing else matters to them
you have to have a conscious to feel
that way and so no there's not it's a
blind obsession
it lacks empathy thus it makes them so
incredibly dangerous
i i wonder you know it seems like these
things have gotten so much worse
since video
games became so realistic and so violent
uh
have you
done research or you know
learned that that video games uh
struggling even to have we know we want
to blame video games but i don't even
know how to put together a question tend
to just desensitize people to
the actual um results of pulling a
trigger
i think in terms of causation what the
information shows us is that as we
become more disfranchised as individuals
and groups people leave a faith for
example the family units become smaller
or more difficult so this guy talks
about leaving faith and disfranchised
the guest doesn't even really know how
to respond even though john scott wants
to blame video games so uh every country
has violent video games the united
states is not unique in that do you guys
have any idea how much grand theft auto
i played growing up do you have any idea
how many people i have brutally murdered
in a video game since i was like 14
years old with every weapon imaginable
and i have never even thought about
committing a violent act i am not in any
way desensitized to real world violence
if anything the real world violence and
the shootings we are what we've become
accustomed to because it is so frequent
but it is not the video games and other
countries with tons of video games don't
have this problem there's a ton of
gaming in europe there's a ton of gaming
in argentina in south korea there's an
insane video gaming world they don't
have a gun violence issue they also
don't have nearly as many guns which is
an interesting thing they also mostly
have access to mental health treatment
if you believe that that is actually the
the primary cause
and then we are a country without any
real access to that treatment you also
have to consider that so they've been
pushing this for 40 years or longer
first it was movies then video games we
have academic work on the topic
uh the best findings that i'm able to uh
uh find
uh include work from eric ashar who has
been a guest on this show talking about
this from the university of
massachusetts
a study called violent video games do
contribute to aggression and and what
the study found is that while violent
video games
can generally
promote aggression in some general sense
they don't make non-violent people
randomly go out and do shootings and
most importantly most importantly um air
as eric ashara has made clear
uh
it is impossible to link video games to
mass shootings and this has been studied
and this has been debunked so i guess we
shouldn't be surprised
that fox news so quickly went to that
they seem to often do it
but it is not based in evidence let me
know your thoughts and remember that
monday memorial day will have our one
day
membership special i hope that you're on
our newsletter at davidpakman.com if you
are monday memorial day you'll be
notified about this great opportunity to
get a highly discounted membership
as i've said many times before i believe
that the secret to
personal finance and it's not really a
secret isn't about timing the market or
picking individual stocks it's basically
asset allocation and in order to
determine asset allocation you've got to
know all of the different assets that
are out there that's why i joined a
community called alts and we asked them
to be a sponsor
alts is a newsletter that makes the
world of alternative assets accessible
to anyone even if you're new to it alt
does the research on alternative assets
that no one else is doing right now and
they break it down for readers in a way
that's nuanced and it's easy to digest
and honest and provides you with just a
ton of valuable insight into
what assets are there and this could be
baseball cards collectibles music rights
comic books video games the alts
newsletter demystifies
these investment markets for you their
recommendations have a track record that
you can check out on their website and
you can also learn about the alts one
fund which contains a blend of
alternative assets including
collectibles and art and music rights
and the things that i've mentioned you
can find that and the free newsletter at
davidpakman.com
slash alts the link is down below